au plus profond des océans
[Musique]
il existe un monde fait de mystère
de beauté et d'émerveillement
excusez-moi misr salut je m'appelle 10
etc et volés à lyss et ça c'est notre
colonie
[Musique]
c'est super ouais sauf qu'il n'a jamais
le droit de sortir de toute notre vie
c'est ce que je t'ai dit à propos d'
aller voir mais si j'avais écouté grand
père je n'aurais jamais découvert ces
magnifiques oeuvres d'art humaine qu'est
ce que c'est je crois que c'est un être
humain il n'a pas l'air très futés non
venez on va explorer a juste est ce que
tu vas le laisser faire regarder ces
trucs incroyables s'avère dangereux
[Musique]
bolani
qu'est ce que j'ai fait nous sommes
piégés dit certains ne retrouve nathan
c'est le seul animal à ses portes pour
bouger ses rochers il est dans la cité
des hommes
par ici ont cherché les sites et des
âmes vous savez au ça il faut se laisser
porter par les courants chauds de
l'ouest mais vous ne pouvez pas partir
maintenant hein ça me remet à ma vie je
parie que tu rêves de devenir la lumière
de ma vie mais l'apologie l'engagement
ça fait peur d'ailleurs tout peur
c'est un voyage extrêmement dangereux je
peux vous aider je peux vous protéger
contre les prédateurs mais tu es un
prédateur
approché
ou est ce que vous nagez comme ça les
jeunes
vous me faites un spectacle ou générer
tous en ceviche ce que c'est clair
j'évite chére me mariaggi titan
coriandre onians épicentre est horrible
et bizarrement ça fait presque envie
ok les amis vivent à rien
datant de la veille arrivée la colonie
comptent sur nous salutations singulière
créative que c'est lui qui tue souvent
embêté moi de vous présenter mon
équipage à l'examen sa vie sa lutte avec
ça il serait peut-être temps de
continuer les amis de continuer notre
route
mais où est ce qu'il va chercher tout ça
chez moi bien sûr
[Musique]